breaking moments ago the Department of
Justice to the credit of Bill Barr he is
doing his job they have just released a
previously classified version of the
2017 this is the scope memo the dates
matter hear from deputy AG rod
Rosenstein now this is the scope what he
what he's giving Muller instructions
marching orders if you will to go out on
his collusion witch-hunt
now the get this the memo tas Muller
with investigating not just fake
collusion but also investigating Michael
Flynn for bogus that non-existent Logan
Act violation a $17.99 law no American
has ever been convicted of and to
investigate Papadopoulos for being an
agent of Israel now the timeline is key
look at this remember when this memo was
written in August of 2017 the FBI
already knew that the steal dossier was
debunked they already knew they knew it
in January of that year now there's only
one source for the dirty dossier and
that was Christopher steel by August of
2017 they had long known that this was
all Russian disinformation in fact they
knew this by the winter of 2017 because
we now know from the IG FISA report that
the primary sub source quote raised
doubts about the reliability of Steel's
reporting and get this the IG also found
that when the bureau talked to the
primary sub source again January 2017
this order goes out in August of that
year the source told them that the
dossier was full of misinformation and
lies and steel quote misstated or
exaggerated the primary sub sources
statements they already had every reason
to know that there was no collusion no
good-faith basis to ever move forward
and now here we are eight months later
and they're still using the dirty
dossier and don't forget the FBI had no
derogatory information on Flynn remember
they were ready to close out that
investigation in December of 2016
struck racism please don't close this
out call me allows it
I sent them in chorus I wouldn't do it
in another administration
Rosenstein had access to all of this
information
he signed the fourth and final FISA
application he's in trouble too my
humble opinion but he still gave Muller
the okay to go on his collusion
witch-hunt after they knew and had all
the information that it was false and
call me and Rosenstein signed off on the
subsequent fraudulent paese applications
again with the bulk of information being
Hillary Clinton's bought and paid for
unverifiable Russian disinformation
dossier you can't write this in a novel
and look at this memo again is there
anything about taxi medallions loan
applications in here hmm everything we
have been telling you about the deep
state's abuse of power is now as clear
as it has ever been
now the good news I am told and I have
confidence actually in a deep state day
of reckoning is very close everything we
told you was right
everything the mob and the media told
you an Adam Schiff oh by the way Adam
Schiff tick tock not gonna be a good day
tomorrow
gessie earlier today Acting Director of
National Intelligence Rick Grinnell he
called on the congenital compromised
liar Adam Schiff to release secret
Russia probe transcripts that the
committee had already voted to make
public back in 2018 tomorrow just
hearing what do I know I'm just a
talk-show host could be the day that the
corrupt compromised congenital liar ship
is completely exposed then the question
of possible crimes he may have committed
that needs to be probed deeply now by
the way the office director national
intelligence writing quote all of the
transcripts with our required redactions
can be released to the public without
any concerns of disclosing classified
material adding that if ship fails to
follow through on his promise the
transcripts can be released directly
that's right from the office of Director
of National Intelligence this is what
training the swamp
looks like it's taken this long why I
don't know this is what holding shift
the deep state actors like Call Me
Rosenstein accountable for their lies
their abuse of power their
RUP ssin they're shredding of the rule
of law in the Constitution also sources
telling me tonight there is much more to
come
buckle up it's going to be a bumpy ride
the next 12 14 days
director ray hope you're taking notice a
lot of people don't like you tonight and
don't trust you are you going to show
them you are committed to cleaning up
the Department of the FBI the premier
law enforcement agency in the world
in other words will you restore that
credibility or will you cover for Comey
and other deep state actors and cave to
the mob in the deep state now by the way
just didn't we have a statement from
Devon Nunez to John Solomon on this
bombshell quote this information was
redacted until now for one single reason
to hide the fact that the false
allegations from the steel dossier were
included in Muller's scoping memo in
other words a bunch of Lies paid for by
the Democrats used to engineer the
appointment of a special counsel to drag
the president the Trump administration
through the mud for years he came close
to bringing this country to the brink of
a constitutional crisis